[Music]
it's the worst question i've ever heard
i asked how are you you know i actually
really like most receivers oh god are
you recording look i bought an actual
goddang lion
[Applause]
[Music]
well oh well
hello media
the same media that ranked me last
quarterback in my draft class
the same media that said i wasn't a
quarterback it wasn't just bill paulian
yo all started
was josh rosen leading a game-winning
drive on monday night football last
night
do most running backs throw for
442 yards
i will no longer be disrespected
quoth this raven
never more
tried to commit me
our only loss this season was to the
raiders and i don't know if you've been
watching the news but i got my revenge
that's right i am the lamar jackson and
i am not afraid to die
ask your questions i will destroy the
answers
let's get this kicked off you there on
the left
hey this is dollar b2 what do you have
to say to the lamar haters
dollar b2
i have to say to all of the lamar haters
like i say to any individual lamar hater
you do not know yourself
for i am lamar jackson greatness
embodied in a human and to hate lamar
jackson is to hate yourself
seek help dollar be to seek help next
question
hey this is camp daddy
just wanted to say this is the most
pointless [ __ ] ever
hello camp daddy
it seems that fate has brought us two
together to ask these deep questions of
existence
such as a question that isn't really a
question but more a statement good
well camp daddy
meet your fate or rather a mirrored
version of yourself for we are all
connected in this one thing and as you
are doing something pointless i am doing
something point four
being the lamar jackson on our way to
greatness
we are all witnessing something that has
never happened before and camp daddy i'm
so glad that they brought us together
for this moment your your fate was to
ask this and mine is to be the greatest
quarterback in the nfl
next
question excuse me
hey lamar this is sage castro was that
back soreness earlier this year from
carrying the team
hello sage catcher
very complex question with a complex
answer
maybe next question excuse me lamar over
here
over here
hey lamar this is uh time is key seven
are you a running back
time is key seven
no i'm not a running back
in fact i hate running backs so much
that i had all i was injured in the
preseason
latavius you better watch out cause yeah
it was me and i'd do it again i'm only
ever gonna pass for the rest of my life
just despite you thomas g7
you know what matter of fact i'm gonna
hack into the bleacher report service
i'm gonna look up your ip address mm-hmm
i'm gonna drive to your home where you
live chattanooga tennessee i'll drive to
chattanooga i'm away to my car and i'll
wait for you to go to work you'll
probably drive what a toyota echo yeah
some kind of car like that going to your
place of employment probably at a jamba
juice or or whatever
and i'm gonna go to that jamba juice and
i'm gonna say you know what he's not a
cashier he's actually a running back
and i'll keep repeating it i'll just say
it over and over again he's a running
back thomas key seven is a running back
and you know what
all the other customers at that time
produce will say well he must be a
running back because lamar jackson only
speaks truth and they will no longer
take you seriously as a cashier and you
know what happens next
you will go broke time is k7
and then you will die alone
next question
hey lamar this is will easy do you think
you deserve to be in the mvp
conversation
we're lazy
this is an easy question
i always deserve to be in the mvp
conversation i've i've done something
that most people haven't in the nfl
career and that's to win an mvp in the
first place
last year i gave aaron rodgers a gift
he's elderly we should respect our
elders but who was my competition this
year got kyler murray i got my good
friend justin tucker he's gonna punt him
to the moon
now josh allen that that's a gangly dude
who's way too goofy to do what it takes
to be mvp and we got a surfer bro from
the chargers yeah he's surfing bro
totally dude all that now go ahead and
ask what your mom thinks about justin
justin justin herbert um
[Music]
she'll be like oh justin herbert
is that someone you went to grade school
with
[Music]
he's so respectable but if you ask her
about the lamar jackson
she'll know the answer and she will
respond
oh lamar jackson he who can only be
uttered in the most deferential way
why that's the elite quarterback of the
baltimore football ravens
that
is an mvp caliber
candidate worthy of being in the mvp
conversation next question
this is a brooklyn n10
do you miss mark ingram
brooklyn and tan
mark ingram
now that is a soulful brother who is now
going on to where all the great backs of
the league go to to run out their days
in the great farm i call the houston
texans where you will duke it out in
what will amount to meaningless
meaningless gains but doing what you
love mark ingram i say this with all the
love in my heart
i got you
now now you're playing with rex burke
head and running around all the mother
rb's on a team that's going nowhere fast
but i'll tell you what once a raven
always a raven kakako
next question
go ahead you there on the left
hey lamar this is why not win
uh so why did you ever admit that your
cramps were a case of the poops why not
win great username
i should get this tattooed underneath
the big old football that's already on
my chest
now cramps
a case of the poops these are both
things that lamar jackson has to suffer
as a part of being a human being and to
be frank with you i cannot tell the
difference between these two bodily
movements okay they're really the same
to me cramps poops they're the same
matter of fact
alcohol cranks poops boobs i call number
two's number eights because no matter
what lamar jackson does it's going to be
great i encourage you why not win in
your life to say that when you're going
to do a number eight then you're doing
the lamar jackson hey i ate too much
taco bell i'm gonna do a lamar jackson
later and people will say that's a
that's a noble thing you're taking on
next question
excuse me lamar over here
hi mr jackson this is rusnak 11.
can you be my dad
russ knack 11.
this is uh
this is an implicitly sad question with
hopefully a jubilant reply
russ knack 11
i'm already your dad
next question
yeah go ahead do that on the right
hello lamar this is past two to italians
who's winning a fight between fangio and
harbaugh pastor italian's uh
not gonna lie your username is vaguely
vaguely racially incessantly at best and
uh maybe a slur worse now who's winning
the fight between fangirl and harbaugh
now harbaugh i mean
i've seen humber up close and personal
and uh that's not a lot that's going to
put me in between one of his fists and
her face not gonna do it now not to
mention he survived growing up in house
harbor i mean he grew up with jim
harbaugh that's anybody who survived
that
they've got god's favor behind them now
a lot of people are gonna tell you oh
well for angel he's he's old he's old
he's getting up there in age i i would
tell you we're doing fenjo a favor you
know he's already close to the end let's
just go ahead get him over the finish
line send them on up to heaven you know
he can be reunited with his ancestors
and all the elder greats that have gone
before him that's that's what i would do
pastor italians next question excuse me
lamar over here
hey lamar this is dwayne young software
are you fast or is everyone slow dwayne
young
these are the questions that keeps lamar
jackson up at night
questioning the
the rules of this universe and the
physics that bound us all am i fast or
is everyone slow dwayne young
i don't think this is either or
these are not mutually exclusive events
in our universe
dwayne young lamar jackson is the
epitome of fast
and at the same time everyone is slow
lamar jackson fast
everyone's slow matter of fact you look
up the definition of fast you're gonna
see my face
next question excuse me lamar over here
over here
go ahead you there on the right
hello lamar this is not john marant do
you think you have better hands than
hollywood brown
not not john marantz this is
this is a get a question questioning the
the rules of nature
now better hands of hollywood brown i
you know
he's got great hands i've got great
hands that's why we're both good at our
crafts
now i can't possibly answer this
question in in sub 10 years this is
something that will be asked by
scientists decades from now now
something we're much closer to answering
is whether john lennon has the better
hands outside of paul mccartney okay
because those two gentlemen on the
beatles made amazing music i mean have
you heard the beatles anthology did you
listen to yellow submarine i mean my god
we are blessed to be in the same
timeline as those gentlemen now
it's better hands than hollywood brown
it's between me and god not not john
miranda i'm gonna take one more question
after this just one more
better be a good one
this has been great so far yeah go ahead
hey lamar this is buckeye six one four
hey buckeyes six in the playoffs this
year
buckeye 6-1-4
i'ma show up in the playoffs
just like i always show up
i'ma be there clean it up
shoelace is tired
chest
throwing throwing the greatest games
that anyone has ever witnessed but
that's not all that i'm gonna show up
i'm gonna show up in the playoffs i'm
gonna show up in the regular season i'm
gonna show up in the postseason imma
show up in your dreams
imma show up in your nightmares
imma show up when your eyes are open
imma show up when your eyelids are
closed
because i am omnipresent
behold
greatness embodied in the lamar jackson
buckeye 614
ah that's enough for me big trust you
know what that's enough from all of
y'all i appreciate the time but there's
nothing that i could tell you anymore
that you couldn't see from the baltimore
ravens barely beating the carson wentz
lead courts now i have to prepare for
the charges now justin herbert or as i
like to call him by his french name
justin a bear
is coming into my town in their fancy
pot of blues and
they expect to win
well guess what sleepyheads the game's
at 10 a.m your time
and lamar jackson
why he has never slept lamar jackson out
now let's check in on dan campbell
football has
betrayed me
[Music]
you